[Music]
when the Mackey's convert an abandoned
Roadhouse into a country music dance
school they awaken an old evil
[Music]
the possessed fight to save their souls
[Music]
13 o clock
[Music]
well it's us again yeah and this is
gonna be a haunting episode yeah we
actually I had actually planned on doing
a true-crime episode this week but then
I okay this this is an episode that or
an episode of a haunting that I had
written down and I wasn't gonna actually
do it for a few more months uh-huh then
I thought you know what you said we
haven't done yet and a lot of people
seem to like those right and I wanted to
do this one specifically because it was
a good episode of a haunting but there's
also a lot of other yeah stuff about it
like a lot of other paranormal shows
have gone there and all this other kind
of yeah there's a lot easier for me to
research it if there's like a lot of
information about it yeah I was the one
to actually kind of recommended it with
this is the one we should do next
because of that it's a famous case it's
not really my favorite episode of the
haunting it's a good one it's a good one
it's just not someone yeah there's other
ones like monster in the apartment
though that I think a little bit but we
have to do that one yeah you know
there's just a lot of good ones too and
you know sometimes it's because just a
gag factor on so on the song you're not
a gag factor whatever don't you know
like the laugh factor yeah on some of
them you know like where's that raccoon
well there's other stuff like that out
of that series not as funny as where's
that raccoon or the deer a child
Mackie's doesn't have anything in there
that stands out to me that that is like
gag-worthy you know from our trigger you
know laugh worthy that much it's kinda I
think it's kind of you know it's kind of
a serious episode I don't know if I buy
every detail of this story yeah get into
that well the interesting thing about it
is that a lot of urban legend
yeah growing up about it about its
history and stuff like that and we're
not really sure like how much of it is
actually true exaggerated you know I'm
not necessarily saying that people
haven't seen paranormal [ __ ] happening
there I mean they might have it's just
that I don't know like a lot of the
stuff about who the spirits are supposed
to be in suraíh I don't know how
accurate historically accurate any of
that once you get it once we get into it
I question how could they know yeah like
where this information is coming from
it's kind of shaky yeah so it doesn't
mean there isn't some kind of a
phenomenon going on it's too
differential right it's just I think
some I think the expose some of the
explanation of this phenomenon it's kind
of mythical or legendary that's good all
right before we get into that let's do
our regular shout outs
um faceless Bell and I always shout that
out you know that if you haven't got it
yet if you read it and liked it please
leave a review I'm still working on
volume two it's like girl a little
slower than I thought but I did actually
get a couple chapters done this week so
you must be on rock 10 then chapter 10
or so chapter 9 chapter 9 yeah and it's
actually it's less than 20 chapters and
some of the chapters are longer than
others because you know if you read the
first volume you know that each chapter
is a year and some of the years had like
a [ __ ] ton of cases and some of the
years only had one or two you know some
of the chapters are gonna be longer than
others but hopefully I'm still hoping to
have it out like by early summer you
know I'm really gonna add a recording
doc yeah and well you know that takes
much longer but I at least want the
print and ebook up by summer and then
hopefully the audiobooks you but we'll
see how that goes if you didn't see our
last movie review it was David
Cronenberg's the brood yeah one of my
favorites it's so good it's like I
hadn't seen it in such a long time and I
forgot how much I liked it yeah so
that's a therapy I haven't seen it also
check out our Zazzle store at zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock and all our t-shirts
and
yeah and tote bag and hopefully all of
our $20 up patrons have got their tote
bags I have heard from a couple people
that got them yeah they like them that
have already got him yeah so um just
because I said about last week I think I
said him out on the 15th or 16th if you
haven't got it let me know but they
should all this should have probably all
got there by now except maybe for the
one guy in Australia yes and also
speaking of patreon we have we want to
welcome two new patrons Duncan and Tina
hi and thank you thanks guys
and also I would like to give a shout
out to two people who gave us some
donations on PayPal yeah and that would
be Eric and Richard thank you very much
thank you very much has haters yeah that
was that was very very nice of you
wouldn't much appreciate it during
myself all right so we're gonna do some
news stories this one the like you know
you know like I said I'd like to do like
a paranormal one whenever we do like a
paranormal show I couldn't really find
anything that substantive this week that
came out on the paranormal front but
then I found another one that I want to
talk to you too so the first one I want
to talk about is just this little this
was actually in the March 21st edition
of the British paper the Express and
evidently there's a guy I don't know
what his name is actually but he posted
a video now he says that he'd been
hearing stuff in his office or his
workplace or whatever and he wanted to
like set up a CCTV camera and see what
was going on and everything so the video
which is on YouTube as far as I know
like I found it I'll put it in our
YouTube video it's just it's really
short it's just like 30 seconds or
something like that and it's called
ghost boy under the stairs yeah and it's
basically and I hate that they filmed it
in [ __ ] portrait mode yeah so sorry
about that I hate Russians like them
yeah they just that's just how they
filmed it but um yeah so it's like it's
like a staircase and then there's like a
little figure the Canada looks like it
could be a little ghostly kid or
something like that
yeah kind of floating or walking kinda
all right you know
it's a trip it's cool looking but you
know it is I don't know well like I said
there's not like a huge amount of
details about it that was one of the few
paranormal stories that looks like this
might have been something you can modify
on like moviemaker or something like
that
yeah well that's the thing it's like you
really can't you know bake anything you
can fake stuff super easy yeah so I
don't know like at this point I just I
don't know what to think anymore yeah
it's a cool-looking video do I think
it's a ghost now probably not yeah but
uh yeah so if you want to go if you're
if you're not watching our YouTube show
where I'm actually putting the video
into our video it is kind of creepy shot
though
it is kind of a creepy shot then you can
go on YouTube and it's called ghost boy
under the stairs and it you can watch it
on there it's only a few seconds long so
supposedly filmed at 2:00 a.m. on March
17th this little ghost okay yeah it's
funny because you can't trust video
anymore remember video photographic
evidence was usually the evidence to end
all be all now you can make any image
you want you could actually get a real
photograph of a UFO coming down landed
and some aliens coming out and shaking
hands with other people and leaving and
people go down to fake and it might be a
real video well that's what I mean it's
like there's just no like I said you can
do it so it easy
you know like newspapers like the Weekly
World News have been doing it since
[ __ ] seventies when you had to cut
everything out by hand and all it looks
fake it did what it is like now you can
make everything look super realistic so
it's like you can't believe anything
anymore
go to the movies they can make yeah
exactly I'm gonna go to Hollywood so the
other news story so I said what that
wasn't really that exciting of a news
story so I wanted to find another one
and this one actually kind of yeah made
sort of big news
yeah probably anybody familiar with you
know paranormal or UFO type right
circles is familiar with the atacama
skeleton yeah it's a little bitty a
little bitty like a six inch skeleton
right and body it looks like a little
alien yeah it was found in Chile around
2003 and ever since it was found it is
very
looking it's very small but then it
looks like it almost looks like a little
grown-up skeleton but it's super tiny
and then the head is kind of like big
and pointy and it has like weird shaped
eyes and so yeah but not as big as it
should be for being an infant yeah it's
actually almost adult proportions if you
really put it next to an infant yeah you
go damn that head is a little much
smaller than it should be and the body
because of it's so thin and elongated it
looks kind of like an adult skeleton
yeah it's weird it's pretty [ __ ] up
looking right but almost as soon as this
little skeleton was found predictably
all that UFO people was like well
obviously it's because it doesn't kind
like the Starchild you know yeah it's
the same kind of thing it's like an
appointee head and like these weird like
alien looking eyes and [ __ ] like that it
was a mummified skeleton so from the
start scientists that actually studied
this thing yeah they knew that it was a
human skeleton that it was like a that
it was a fetus obviously a premature
yeah baby as a backstory the person who
brought this to the I the public eye and
gave it to these scientists was a guy
named Steven Greer and if he's a big UFO
UFO consumers right yeah yeah you know
this [ __ ] here man if you ever watching
his movies most of it he's trying
desperately to tie UFOs in with young
men and their underwear working out
every one of his UFO movies involves
young men in their underwear
working out talking about
extraterrestrials that may be extra
testicles I don't know there's something
something like that I don't you know how
funny yeah I don't know just I'm just
just saying well the thing just say that
like Steven Greer Z but it's like a
weird like which is fine but it's like
why don't you just separate those two
things like why don't you make like a
UFO thing over here and then you can
make later some for and over because if
you're gonna make it just seems weird to
like that just just try and like not
wait force that into you like a UFO
thing when it's like nothing to do with
it
like specific fetish oh yeah it's not
doing anything for me if it's just guys
working out in their underwear there's
you know stretch young strapping young
men into his clutches I guess I don't
know
just like the old exploitation directors
of Hollywood I guess you know yeah come
again would you know that would have to
have make excuses for his rostrum so
where that's what I have to wear an
angora sweater and this scene just
because yeah yeah so yeah all right so
anyway pretty much since the beginning
even though this is very famous skeleton
and UFO circles you know scientists have
known from the beginning this is a human
skeleton well now they've done a
complete you know genetic breakdown of
its DNA and stuff like that at a
Stanford University and the University
of California San Francisco and they
have discovered that this little
skeleton I mean we were talking about
this on our walk today I said you know
how when some people say they won the
genetic lottery yeah okay this poor kid
this is the opposite of that this baby
pretty much had every genetic mutation
you could I mean you know what I mean
it's just it's a horrible I mean
obviously the kid didn't live it was
born prematurely yeah
well stuff like that it doesn't have two
of its ribs and you know it's it's just
really it looks like the like you said
the proportions look adult even though
it's obviously very more time like 2 / 2
painting they thought it might have
progeria - right thing well I don't know
if it's if that specifically but they
did say that it did have some kind of
rapid aging genetic mutation that made
it have the proportions of a
six-year-old kid right rather than a
fetus yeah they also said that it had
cranial ectodermal dysplasia and
greenberg skeletal dysplasia and also
yeah that that would that caused the
pointed skull with the ridges and stuff
that's what causes that there's also
mutations and a couple
genes that cause the femur to be shaped
like a club and it had several other
mutations that cause deformities at the
arms but the interesting thing about it
I would said it also had scoliosis I'm
not sure I'm pronouncing this right but
Ahlers Danlos syndrome which is a joint
or connective tissue disease the
interesting thing though is that they
what they think caused it this is the
skeleton itself is only 40 years old it
was magnified when they found it like I
said they found it in Chile they think
that the birth defects were may be
caused by nitrate poisoning because
there's a lot of bad in the soil like
from mining and stuff like that so women
probably working around fertilizers yeah
yeah something of that nature so they
think that's what caused it but they
said it's interesting because they had
never really seen all of these
particular this particular suite of
genetic abnormalities like in one
individual it was mutated to hell pretty
much and so they said it in a lot of
ways it's useful that they did that
because you know now that we've seen
that and we know what probably caused it
you know we can help other people that
had that so I guess that's why there's
such a mystery you know it wasn't
anything deep dark secrets some girl
working and working in the field had a
stillbirth yeah and basically just
buried it or put it somewhere may have
never been buried or it would have been
lost probably wrapped up in storage
somewhere yeah maybe it looks like it
was dried out it was it was mummified
yeah she laid a very high altitude dry
air okay
yeah but that's why so like I said not
an alien no just a tragically tragically
yeah genetic whole host of genetic yeah
the other thing that was kind of like
this was that Starchild skull yeah the
last I heard was that that wasn't really
made out of bone it was more closer to
tooth enamel yeah and that's probably
something similar to that you know and
that is old though they found that was
centuries old yeah that was some kind of
a Mayan or Aztec ink and probably
something like that you know
Mesoamerican Indian and I think they
found it buried with her or basically
buried in a cave but not really you know
they just laid him in a cave yeah I
couldn't display along with its mother
of a gentleman yeah and you know a lot
of mutations back then you know though
yeah I don't know what was going on in
those old city
there's lots of inbreeding cannibalism
toxic they were around in a toxic waste
yeah you know well when I told you that
I find that it will care so yeah I think
could be you could bring any kind of kid
to birth there was no way to yeah and
there's seem to be some some evidence
for the Mesoamericans to kind of like
honoring birth defected children is some
kind of a signal from the gods yes it
kept them but I told you I was telling
you this earlier today that years ago I
read this book and I think it's just
called mutations I can't remember who
wrote it and so fascinating but I mean
it's scary and like depressing as all
hell but it was a fascinating book
because it just tells you you know all
the things that can go wrong and it
doesn't really take that much it was
like one problem letter off and
something like that and then you just
have all these horrifying mutations and
reading that I'm like now I'm kind of
shocked that most people come out pretty
much normally so easy for things to go
wrong she was like a computer program
you know yes change one letter in the
code and the program yes it's exactly
like that it's like sometimes it can
happen and nothing bad will happen but
sometimes one letter changes interest so
yeah I think we kind of evolved to have
a certain amount of errors in our
genomes and we're still basically
healthy okay we all have some errors in
there oh yeah of course they're not
coming to fruition
nothing's they're not doing anything
yeah evidently a lot of our genetic code
is just stuff that's turned off yeah how
to make gills and how to make scales and
you know the insect stuff yeah you can
see you can have a lot of errors in that
and it doesn't make any difference cuz
it's turned off yeah all right
so those are our news stories so now
let's get into our main topic we're
talking about the episode of a haunting
that was about Bobby Mackey's yeah and
we're also gonna talk well we're gonna
talk a little bit about the case I'm
gonna talk a little bit about Zach a
little bit about Ghost Adventures
who's Ghost Adventures went to this
place
now they say they went three times but
they did like it they did two shows and
actually Bobby Mackey's was their
premiere episode episode 1 season 1 he's
been back to it several times yeah
and they spent a lot of time yelling
yelling and challenging ghosts that's
Zach
yeah I'm not talking about the haunting
handles it differently out actually like
the way haunted the haunting handles
itself on its programs you know I mean
you know I'm trying to go down there and
confront anything they're just gonna
tell you the storage or to reenact it
yeah which I actually appreciate yeah so
this was actually not season 2 episode
right I think it's season 2 episode 7
the episode itself is called gateway to
hell yeah which you know will become
clear alright so let's talk about and I
hope you guys are falling asleep but
this is an headphones off because last
time we've given people nightmares yeah
we're talking serial killers
yeah that's true yeah alright what's the
more bright commute to work so yes to
our new listeners that show up you know
when we do these old haunting up do
these old haunting episodes it's got a
tribute to a haunting and we kind of
poke fun fun at it sometimes too you
know and we kind of point out things
that come maybe don't look right or
maybe they do look right just depends on
the situation so I guess we can get down
to it yeah just kind of give us a
background in case yeah one thing I
would like to mention is that I mean if
you've watched as many episodes of a
haunting as we have they have a stable
of actors that they use over and over
again yeah so it should be noted that
the woman that plays Bobby Mackey's wife
and this reenactment is the same woman
that was on the haunting of Summerwind
that's right she's been on a bunch of
other ones to answer one it's almost
part of the crustal spirit it is and the
woman at the end of the episode he plays
the psychic who comes in like checks the
place out yeah it's the weird forehead
woman from from the Billy Beane episodes
yes
please she forehead means mop her her
hairline is kind of she's kind of far
back on her head
yeah so it's just like you know she
can't help but but I'm just like yet
sorry she appears that this would seem
like later on as a psychic so like I
said we get all these same raccoon
that's always gonna be raccoon man and
the woman that's in this one and there
was in haunting someone when she said I
should set up up too but yeah so this
one and I was in Wilder Kentucky yeah
now the building and this is interesting
too because Bobby Mackey's they usually
use a different house like for the
reenactment obviously yeah now this one
I was actually surprised to find what I
was looking at it they actually use the
real place yeah and it is that dumb
although I tell you what
later on when Zack goes there to do his
little show at it it looked a lot better
yeah it looked like they've made some
improvements I wanted het wonder if they
have something to do the ghost tourism
signs on the outside up there so I would
think that that's another thing that
kind of maybe get that yeah Bobby Mackey
and his wife since wife's name is Janet
yeah and they bought this place in 1978
yeah listen Wilder Kentucky think about
that 78 that's a year after Star Wars a
new hope and I was a long it's been it's
a successful business yeah yeah and
Bobby Mackey I'm not just like I'm not
up on you know old school country music
or anything like that so I don't know
how famous he was at the point that he
bought but at that time you know my
uncle you know red not talk about it in
ya know poltergeist he was a
country-western performer during that
era and even in California it was a big
scene yeah yeah I was coming back all
this stuff this Garth Brooks stuff that
was actually much later that wasn't yeah
way after the popularity craze oh yeah
country western country western had a
really big resurgence in the early 80s
late 70s yeah California
so like I said ah yeah you know okay so
evidently it's Bobby Mackey's dream he's
always wanted to open like a music-hall
you know live venue country-western bar
and stuff like that and he buys this
place which he names after himself now
it's funny because in in the episode
he's all excited about it and it looks
like a dump you know because then
there's like it's all gross and dirty
and everything and he's just all oh I
can imagine who he's all excited and
then he brings his wife there yes the
hunting of summer when ladies yeah and
she just makes a face like she gets out
of the car and looks at it and makes her
face like [ __ ] my life yeah like she
farted in her spacesuit so she goes out
and she's kind of like now the
interesting thing is I just have the
image of being in this spacesuit
alright nevermind go ahead well it's
funny because I actually every time you
say that it reminds me of because I had
actually 4001 well I first I first heard
it on Mystery Science Theater I think it
was I can't remember which episode it
was but I think it was cry that's what I
doing Dave turns out it's not funny at
all when you fart in a space oh I think
it was Phantom Planet actually I think
that was the episode pod bay doors out
so Bobby Mackey the real Bobby Mackey is
on there talking now his wife only
wanted to be seen in silhouette yeah
which I thought was weird but whatever
so she's on there talk amber Shia and
she was kind of like well I was she
wasn't jazzed obviously about buying
this place and but she's like well
that's what he always wanted so I just
kind of went along with it because you
know how that happens Brooke so man
gonna be a man man gonna be a man and
this is what you want to do so they're
like okay fine say could now the first
thing that happens is basically the
first time he brings her to the place to
show it to her yeah the door opens by
itself
yeah so she she says she sees the the
doorknob going around and it opens up
and she's like hey did you see that he's
like
what are you talking about is you know
then whatever come on let's go check
this [ __ ] out right so they go in there
now immediately Janet says that she did
not have a good feeling about the place
like she walks in and she's like ooh I
like it in here is like not just because
it was gross and dirty I was gonna be a
lot of work and [ __ ] like that but she's
like I just had a bad feeling it seemed
like oppressive and all this other kind
of [ __ ] and apparently and I'm not
totally sure how true this is but the
bar that it had been before evidently
there'd been like a bunch of murders
like fights and so I mean fights you
know it's a bar what are you gonna do
but I mean evident there had been like
six homicides I think when that which
which was closing down if a bars been
there for a long time that happens
remember like you know where we hang out
at a bar yeah just up the street and
this is right there on orange F taboo
when that place was called taboo two
doors down I think there was a couple
guys that got shot and killed in there
uh yeah I think yeah I think you're
right and then somebody you remember uh
what's that one bouncer that we had that
nap now works with the jaws right yeah
yeah yeah
remember that bouncer Josh he kicked
that one guy out that dude when she saw
the door hanging back with it with that
little 22 pistol started shooting at the
back door yeah you know they caught any
it was so stupid is that the police
department is right there yes they just
came out and arrested him he was drunk
yeah it's done yeah yeah the club we
hang out like the police station is just
right there like three doors down yeah
so yeah so yeah you know then you think
yeah so they buy the place and
everything now they're in there talking
and this guy named Carl Lawson shows up
and he says okay well I worked in this
club when it was when it was the old
owners he's like so I wondered you know
I'm doing handyman [ __ ] and everything
like that so it was like so I wondered
if you would give me a job and stuff so
you know Bobby Mackey's like okay cool
no Carl was kind of the one that told
him yeah this was like a really rough
place a lot of people got murdered there
was fights all the time and [ __ ] like
that I don't think he didn't really on
that reenactment he didn't really tell
them at the beginning
hey this shit's haunted I think he just
basically said
the place ain't so bad they've had a bad
vibe or had a bad history I remember and
you know that there was bad chicken I
knew the ins and outs of the place that
he could help keep it up and running and
so they gave him a little apartment up
in the loft
yeah so you lived there okay he was like
the caretaker and he was there like
pretty much all the time I think the
next major thing that happened if that
was that was the police and no actually
the next thing that happened and this
was a kind of a major thing yeah now
Janet was pregnant at the time no doubt
to the audience when I look at these
cases I always like to look at the
genesis of the case you know the first
things that happened yeah because you
notice the more investigators get
involved in these things especially TV
show type investigators more things
happen or what more claims happen well
one of the things I like about the
hauntings take on this is they talk
about the very beginning of the case the
first things that happen I always think
that that's most important yes at the
time because I think that's probably
closer to the truth and that that is
probably more likely to be something
that actually did happen yeah because as
these other investigators come in
especially if they're with TV shows it's
in their best interest for phenomena to
happen so if they got a claim there's
something having to add more on to it
they're gonna do it once you see sac
running around you hear that did you
hear that you can't hear it pretty much
the whole time that it did you hear that
oh my god Jose ACK I didn't hear
anything
challenge me fight me demon know that
kind of stuff look at the [ __ ] out of it
okay stupid douche yeah
but anyway wait got it hair brushed this
way you got some hair that way and the
other hair go I don't understand it I
don't let her some other hairs going
that way I don't understand what what
he's going he's got Cesar going on one
side you know I'm talking about
and then like kind of like a Marilyn
Mass and like and it's he's not balding
or anything like that
so it's not me works out yeah so it's
not like he's combing it forward to hide
a balls now it's not bald it just looks
like a weird it's crazy like walks
around
supposin you know yeah he's no fight
those ghosts you know yeah but his
biceps okay I want to talk a little bit
about that later I can't believe I just
said to my house I know and I I think I
saw most of them yeah cuz York I
couldn't take it sometimes I think
coffee years I can't I find it hard to
sit there I just really did yeah
but okay so actually the first thing
that happened other than the door
opening that was the first thing to
happen and then and this was kind of a
major thing this was before they even
opened so they were still trying to
clean it up and get it all ready to
getting ready for the public to come in
now Janet who is I think she was five or
six months pregnant
when they bought the place she's in the
kitchen I don't think Bobby Mackey is
there Carl was there but he was in the
other room and she's in there and she
starts here and I think she's like the
pots and stuff like start rattling
around and then she looks in the kitchen
sink and blood starts coming up through
the yeah drain the same noise yeah this
is actually one of the scenes that I
remember the best from this episode this
is one of the scenes I remember best
from this that season oh yeah that was a
pretty good scene yes and I caught in
today this film well so the whole sink
fills up with blood yeah and then
evidently she says that she felt the
hand in the middle of her back pushing
her toward the sink and trying to force
her head down into the blood yeah so
she's like fighting to keep out as soon
as to not get in there and stuff like
that she starts screaming and freaking
and one hand on either side of that
Singh trying to fight it in his pull her
down like a face or something out of
alien yeah it's like trying to push her
down to the simple blood she starts
framing everything Carl comes running in
there and she tells him what happened
but the Bloods gone yeah it's like a
vision now Carl did believe her
however they go and tell Bobby Mackey
yeah and Bobby's like man [ __ ] all y'all
he's a snap town or you're scaring her
yeah even though he hadn't I don't think
it didn't seem like he had told her
anything about any kind of haunting or
anything like that not worried to this
not according to the program so so I
thought the Bobby Mackey was being kind
of a jerk because he was just kind of
like whatever you're just like telling
her these stories and her poor little
lady brain yeah
like imagining which is kind of typical
out of the haunting where the gun is
yeah at first it is yeah mostly Matt
Bobby Mackey to this day doesn't really
believe it
yes he says he's never seen it he said
he said well I'm not discounting that
other people have seen stuff but he says
he's never seen it yeah and he doesn't
think it's haunted or that's what he
says anyway yeah we'll get to that yeah
okay so then the next thing that
happened and this this actually cop saw
this so evidently says I think one of
the strongest incidents is in this case
yeah so the cop is his name's Larry
Hornsby and he was driving past the
place and he sees someone in the window
and it's like the middle of the night
the place is closed it hasn't even
opened to the public yet I don't think
he sees him in the window he's think
someone has broken in yeah so him and
his little partner they go into the
building and then they hear music coming
from the back room so they think
somebody broke in they go back in there
and no one's in there yeah and then they
hear voices like they hear a man and
woman like arguing and then they hear
the door of the club slam yeah
even though no one's out there so they
go out yeah they got spooked and went
out to the parking lot and they were
kind of shaken by it according to the
police witness yes in the program yeah
exam I always thought that police
witness of course is pretty good because
it's hard to get a cop on board with
your story yeah of course there's always
a chance that this might be one of Bobby
Mackey's buddies buddies yeah one of his
regular patrons or something but I think
it's more likely that that's something
like that did happen and like there's
more it was two times two cops there's
more to it because later there was an
accident
yeah somebody got killed right out in
front of that place that day it was the
same night when I don't know no I don't
think it was just in that time period
maybe Hanks later yeah first thing I
killed a car accident wide out in front
of the club and why they were there they
heard the door open up and a woman came
out with some table cloths and gave him
some table cloths that uses to cover the
bodies that were the bodies up and use
him kind of clean up and then after the
crime scene had been cleared the
accident scene had been cleared they go
back to the club to thank that woman and
I think Bobby Mackey's wife said there's
nobody here with just me didn't know
anything about it yeah or actually no
one was in there
yeah so they didn't find anybody said
they didn't know who that woman was and
they said they saw her like plain as day
and she was like a real friend think
they said that she was in the dress and
was barefoot
yeah that's pretty weird yeah so then
the next thing that happened was
apparently now Janet thinks that
whatever is in this club that is
haunting this club has specifically has
some beef with her because it did seem
to attack her a lot in Carl too but like
I said Bobby Mackey's and you never seen
it he never saw anything in there so
evidently they're still kind of cleaning
the place up Carl's up on him he breaks
like a lightbulb or something like that
he goes down to get another one and she
sweeping it up she's at the top of the
stairs and all of a sudden something
starts pushing her down the stairs like
the way they showed it it wasn't just
like push and she fell it was like they
were trying to that there was like a
hand on her it was like trying to like
push her down the stairs like slowly
like it was a force like coming down
like pushing her down the stairs
right and she did eventually fall down
the stairs and she turned around and
looked up when she got to the bottom of
the stairs and she says she saw a guy
like a ghost yeah I just winged out the
way yeah like he was like an old
fashioned clothes or whatever now at
that point they actually had to take her
to hospital because she was pretty badly
hurt she actually gave birth to the baby
because they thought she could have a
miscarriage and the baby only wait I
think they said only weighed like a
pound and a half right I'm assuming that
the baby didn't die because they didn't
bring it back up again
um but yeah the baby was premature
because she fell down the stairs or was
pushed down the stairs by a ghost we're
not really sure which and then it seemed
like it was kind of quiet for a few
weeks and then they opened the club to
the public and Bobby is telling Carl
because I guess Carl is still working
there he's like you know tending bar and
[ __ ] like that and he's like you know
don't be telling people these ghost
stories and all this other kind of [ __ ]
so then later on for some reason Carl is
in the storage room
okay so Carl is in the storage room and
he sees there's like a um there's like a
poem that's like written on the wall or
scratched on the wall there
photos of it online you want to see it I
can't remove says exactly but to pretty
badly written home actually well for
yeah and for whatever reason he finds or
he steps on like a loose floorboard and
he pulls up the floorboard and evidently
there's a diary in there that's like
wrapped in a piece of fabric
now the diary says that it belongs to
someone named Johanna yeah and in this
diary evidently Johanna she was a dancer
there when the club was called the Latin
Quarter and this was like in the 40s or
50s now has anyone ever seen this diary
yeah I don't know I see yeah that's an
interesting question where is this
Diaries have been authenticated because
it was supposedly from the 20s is what
they're claiming no from the 15th from
those babies okay yeah I thought was
said twenties but still even that you
have to date that thing from the 50s to
see if it was really from the pits I
like to see it and the reason why I'm
bringing this up this angle of the story
I have a hard time accepting yeah I'm
not real sure about this one yeah so
evidently Johanna like I said was a
dancer at this club and she was the
daughter of the owner and evidently she
fell in love with a guy that sang there
and apparently her dad did not approve
and use his mob ties or whatever to have
the dude killed so Johanna then poisoned
her dad and then killed herself yeah you
see something like this is just it
sounds too much like a plot from a roman
plenty of documentation about this
particular crime murder suicide murders
and then a murder suicide yeah that's
what I mean as far as I know and you
know if if you've seen it like please
correct me if I'm wrong but as far as I
know there is no record of this
particularly suspicious and and let's
say you're this girl your dad killed
your boyfriend so you're gonna kill your
dumb dad and then kill yourself and
you're gonna bury your diary underneath
the floorboards or where you work that's
usually not what you do before you
commit a murder or a kill yourself is to
take all your stuff and bury him
underneath your work that would just be
a book that was on your
dresser drawer or something on you
nightstand girl yeah in love someone
else but if I have this all right it
does seem very way this sounds
suspicious it sounds like someone trying
to give an explanation
for some phenomena like let's say this
is a mysterious phenomena maybe it's
paranormal there has to be a reason why
it's happening so might be a good idea
to make a reason yeah that's just what
it feels like to me oh I should say I
didn't I said the 50s tonight yeah I
actually meant 30 yeah 30
I thought 20s I was thinking of
something else I don't know yeah yeah a
lot of Records that's what I mean there
should be something and I really don't
think that there is yeah just just that
angle of this just it just it doesn't
ring true to me it just it's easy to THR
too good to be true and very unlikely
that that a diary would be buried
underneath the floorboards of where a
girl work although she said her dad I
guess every time I heard dad over the
place that's true yeah why would you
bury your diary I don't know I'm not
buying that part yeah I have to see that
diary yeah I'd have to have that thing
dated you know talking about yeah I'd
have to send it to a forensic place to
see yeah that's that's from that period
you know yeah that syntax and the
grammar and the spellings yeah that's
from that's from the 30 C it's a good
story though and actually Bobby Mackey
liked the story so much that he wrote a
song about it called Hana yeah you know
put that the end right yeah just a
little bit of Johanna Johanna yeah they
used it on the adventure share that
based on the guys adventure [ __ ] okay
I'll just I'll just put like now put it
on saying good actually let's take a
break right now yeah then we'll we'll
come back and talk about the rest of the
thing and we'll talk about ghost
adventure than all that so we'll be back
in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back talking about a
haunting back now the next thing that
happened on the reenactment was that
Carl who by this point has moved into
the club who lives in an apartment over
the club which as far as I know is still
there
he doesn't live there good he's dead now
but he died a couple years ago but so
he's up there sleeping and evidently the
power goes out so Carl goes down to
check the breakers and he's in the
basement and finds a trapdoor which he
had never seen before so he opens the
trapdoor and there's a really big deep
well and you know it goes all the way
down it's like he came on the
reenactment it looks like it's like
super deep there is a well there you
know there's pictures of it all over the
internet I'll put some in the video it
doesn't look deep I can't tell if it's
just because it's been blocked off or
what the deal is this well apparently is
from when okay the building itself I'm
not sure how long that's been there but
evidently the the basement part of it
used to be part of a slaughterhouse
back in the 1850s yeah like the
foundation right and evidently this well
in the basement was where they used to
toss all the you know leftover God's and
stuff like that that they were using
washing down into the washing down and
because it actually does go into the
Licking River yeah you know so it washes
down into that and actually on the ghost
of the Ghost Adventures show they did
show Zac and them like you know
backtracking through the yeah how much
of the fishing was good outside that
place
yeah probably have 30 pound catfish oh
yeah catfish out there and then at this
point you know since all this weird [ __ ]
is happening they decide they're gonna
look into the history of the building
now here is something that actually did
happen but I don't really know if the
association with the place is all that
authentic yeah so ISM this is a more of
a compelling angle for me yeah yeah
in the late 1800s I think it was 1896
there was a 22 year old woman named
pearl Bryan and she was murdered
now her headless body was found two and
a half miles away from the site of Bobby
Mackey's yeah well that's in the area
but that's really just in the air right
now
- guys were convicted for her murder
yeah their names were Alonzo walling and
Scott Jackson now her head was never
found
so this story grew up that they had
tossed the head down the well of this
slaughterhouse or whatever it was at the
time but when they had to break in to do
that that's what I mean I said why would
you have to talk about the well now see
here's the thing
sacrifice yeah I think that and I think
that might be like a later interpolation
because she was killed she was pregnant
yeah and the two guys who killed her and
they were later hanged for her murder
but they were dental students yeah and
they speculated that they were trying to
give her an abortion and a botched I had
messed it up yeah and they cut off her
head so it would be harder to identify
sounds more likely then sacrifice right
it's like so I can't believe that they
actually really dental students and
there's like teeth abortions how hard
can it be
you know that mean
they knew Anatomy they were just gonna
stick something down in there and pop
ahead of that little yeah I guess so but
yeah that's what he used to do it yeah I
know and so they made a wrong move you
know and she started to bleed now I'm
glad to death yeah and they're like oh
[ __ ] yeah we good trouble we're linked
to her
well maybe please make her
unidentifiable you know I mean or maybe
we'd have some plausible deniability
then they project through that head in
the river all right why would they want
to break into a slaughterhouse and throw
it down inside of a well it just doesn't
sound that's what I mean nothing a
little weird it's like is not what it
because the well went down to the river
anyway why didn't you just throw it in
the river just cut out the middleman
yeah that's right that's you could
breaking an entry is just another crime
they can pin on you right now you're
going out of your way to do that that's
that's ridiculous yeah I think he just
chucked the head may got caught and yeah
sure I buy the Satanic yeah because
later on and I don't know like I said
wear this or you know how long ago this
particular story came about but the
rumor started to swirl that one of the
guys was a Satanist and that he and that
he had actually thrown the head down
there for like sacrificial purposes or
anything just sounds off but like I said
I think really it was just a botched
abortion and they killed her and they
they didn't want to her to be identified
yeah so you know so that's why they
threw that Satanism was not a thing
until Anton LaVey
that's maybe it just seems like kind of
a strange yeah yeah yeah it seems good
for that long ago I'm not saying it's
impossible as it just sounds a little
far-fetched that's unlikely yeah so then
the next thing they decide they're going
to get a psychic to come in there and
this is the forehead lady you know it's
just when it dawned on me that what you
have is you have somebody who's just
trying to tie in every bad crime in the
area to the club oh yeah they were yeah
they brought the head in here and
thinking that yeah so it's kind of like
a literary device well and like I'm
saying it's been I mean evidently it's
been several different nightclubs around
the years now if they found her body in
there
yeah maybe I right go with this yeah but
the body like I said was done two and a
half miles away as a head was never
found that's that's never been confirmed
that they tossed the head there's
everyone just assumed yeah just because
I don't believe in the satanic sacrifice
story and I don't believe in the Johanna
story it doesn't mean that I'm gonna
throw the haunting out the haunting
might be there maybe that somebody's
trying to weave those two other stories
in there to have some kind of an
explanation for why it's it's happening
yeah and of course it's it's better if
you're haunting has a story yeah you can
now sell it as a product which later on
you will get into that because I think
that's kind of what they're doing with
this yeah I should note there was also I
think I forgot to mention this but Carl
actually also reported some sort of
poltergeist activity because like I said
he lived about the club and when he came
down there one night like kind of
cleaning up after everyone else who was
gone all the chairs you know eternal the
chairs and stools like upside down on
the tables and they all started rattling
and Lexington's like flew off the tables
and stuff like that so that freaked him
out yeah not to mention possession
happens in this case yeah all right
we'll get today well yeah that was
pretty much the next thing so Carl stirs
Carl starts acting really weird um he's
actually seen two apparitions which he
presumes are the two guys that killed
bro Brian Eppie he didn't say this but
in the reenactment they had like a
nooses around their necks or whatever
now so they call a psychic and she comes
in there
Patricia Michele her name is that that's
the real lady and she comes in there and
she says that she sees the two guys and
they're standing behind Carl and they
want to use his body to do whatever
they're gonna do
also just a nightclub is this prison and
all so evidently she goes down into the
basement or the cellar and looks into
the well and sees a vision of a severed
head and of course so yeah so that's how
that went
evidently she also talks to a spirit who
says her name is Johanna and she's like
she tries to send Johanna into the light
or what have you and Johanna says she
doesn't want to go right that way you
can keep the haunting going and you can
keep
yes so at this point Carl's starting to
actually weird and it's weird because
they kind of conflate demon possession
with him being possessed by these two
guys right so I don't know how that
works for whatever so they call in a
minister or you know and his two helpers
and they do an exorcism in the kitchen
for whatever reason and evidently they
get the two spirits out of Carl but my
guests they're still around like in the
place now shortly after like this is
kind of getting near the end of the
episode so evidently Carl leaves because
he's just like I you know I can't take
anymore in this place and the way they
filmed the end of the episode they show
Carl leaving and then they show the wife
being like yeah I guess I'm gonna go too
and I was like she just like straight up
left him and she's just like walks up
yes no that's not what happened she
actually as far as I know they are still
married like I said the place is still
open he still owns it but she go going
it will not go in there she has not set
foot in the place for years and years
and years evidently evidently so she
says she hasn't been in there and she we
don't know how yeah he's probably 60 60
to 70 yeah I would think because when
did this episode come out like probably
2006 I think so yeah she she says she
won't set foot in there anymore so
that's the episode and like I said so
okay there's like so much about this
story that I just I don't know how much
of its fully know this is what I'm gonna
say just based upon the preponderance of
the evidence I'd say there's a 50%
chance that the entire cases of
fabrication at a hoax prob about a 40
percent chance that maybe something's
going on there but it's it's been
grossly exaggerated and a lot of legend
has been woven into it yeah I'd say
maybe there's only a 10% chance that
it's happened at exact not know you know
I only see 10 5% chance that this case
is happening exactly as described that's
what I'm thinking I have a feeling that
something happened there that scared
Bobby Mackey's wife
other people saw cops I saw all right it
was some kind of a low-level haunting
and then they made up a bunch of stories
to explain
yeah that got woven into it and they
might not have even made them up on
purpose just think they might have just
heard some stuff yeah oh well that must
be it no oh that must be it you know and
it kind of weave it together because in
Mammoth Mountain poltergeist my aunt and
uncle on their own each one of them kind
had a tendency to try to wanna weave
other things into it oh you know bill
Bixby's kid died up here at Mammoth
Mountain yeah well a lot of people's
kids probably died out there oh well
yeah it's a ski resort yeah it's a ski
resort and it's huge it's yeah it's a
town you know I mean up in the mountains
so just because people have died up
there that does not explaining what's
happening do you think that opal are too
quick so you too quick to find an
explanation find an explanation what
sometimes there isn't and especially you
know in your case oh you know what man
oh you know what up in these mountains
they had the Indians living up here they
must be on an Indian burial ground
that's what I mean that was the next
thing that they jumped maybe there is
not an experience there's maybe maybe if
there's paranormal activity here some
like that maybe this [ __ ] just happened
oh there's Indian burial grounds in this
area we're [ __ ] men dead people in every
area you're at that's what I'm you know
people die really necessarily think
about about Bobby Mackey's too like I
said since it's been a nightclub for a
really long time I don't actually know
if it was a slaughterhouse that's how
the story goes that it was
slaughterhouse that he made honors it
might not have been couldn't find it um
yeah but that's how the story goes you
know I'm not disputing that it's been a
nightclub I'm not disputing even that
there might have been like mobbed up
dudes like you know owning it at some
point because you know that happened I'm
not denying that there was probably some
murders there guys fight in those bars
yeah and you know remember Bobby Mackey
in the program said well it's gonna be
country-western it's not where I could
have any that around here it was a
Western barber yeah country-western spot
it country-western scene was violent
yeah 70s and 80s dudes would get into
big pissing matches sometimes a knife
one another on parking lots or shoot
each other out in parking lots
occasionally it happened in the bar
itself records always been kind of a
macho place
mm-hmm and dude to start fighting and if
they were the wrong element sometimes
they'd kill each other
yeah like
I'm not disputing it I'm straight
enjoying the death with them bar stools
and they have each other beer bottles
you know man guys got killed and like I
said you know if there had been some
kind of mob involvement you know maybe
and I'm not even disputing that there
might have been like the occasional
suicide something like that I mean bad
things happen in those places um but I
don't know I just really think you have
to be careful of trying to atribute of
trying to attribute one you know to tie
the two things together yeah
cuz let's say you have a scenario where
a bunch of people were killed in an area
in one of them and one of those dead
people is now a ghost who's causing all
this yeah maybe two or three of these
people are not ghosts you would be able
to pinpoint any one of them be very hard
yeah yeah how could you positively ID'd
something that is invisible you know I
mean because it ghost could impersonate
a person yeah another person right if
you're a ghost do maybe you're gonna
LARP it you're gonna [ __ ] lie back
I'm the devil you know yeah oh tomorrow
I'm gonna be Rosemary's Baby cuz you
know I'm gonna totally do that yeah you
gonna [ __ ] with people well you know I
wouldn't you yeah I wouldn't you might
get bored being at once otherwise ghost
said well I especially wouldn't trust
with a psychic said be sure there's no
ghosts because a psychic can come in and
I know that a lot of psychics will come
in to a location and they'll be like oh
don't tell me anything about what's
going on but it's like you can look [ __ ]
up about that especially somewhere as
famous as Bobby Mackey's and nowadays
with the internet oh [ __ ] yeah yeah so
you can come in and you already do all
the research online so it's very easy to
come in and go
I see a headless woman her name is
Johanna Johanna Johanna Johanna smirks
something like that yeah well you know
I'm just men pulling out of my ass yeah
I'm not saying that phenomena doesn't
happen there occasionally I would like
to go
I'd like this I would you actually I'd
be interested in going I don't buy any
of the explanations for it then take
that with a grain of salt
yeah same here and now evidently other
people have seen it let's talk a little
bit about the Ghost Adventures show
because yeah we got to talk about that
because the Ghost Adventures show they
actually did interview I mean they
interviewed Bobby Mackey who has like I
said his whole time has said I've never
seen anything here I you know he's like
I'm not doubting people that have seen
it but I've never seen it and you know
this is just my place and I want it to
be known for music but he does have big
signs everywhere that you know they make
a big deal about you know we're not
liable for goose hurt you or anything
like that
you know what I mean it's like a warning
at the beginning and they do have like a
wall where they have like a bunch of
pictures of them and with Zach and with
other paranormal teams of yeah any
Zach's de fancy I mean you got to
understand the burden that Ghost
Adventures is under they're trying to
get an entire season of action-packed
peril excited and they're probably doing
it all in a couple months yeah maybe 90
days worth of work all right so to
accidentally do a job man he's got to be
a entertainer one thing that that show
does do is they do do some interviews
yeah which that's pretty good they did
interview one guy who's kind of a
regular at Bobby Mackey's and he said
that he had seen an apparition in the
bathroom he said that he was washing his
hands in the men's room and the garbage
can next to him went flying across the
room he turned around like what the [ __ ]
and then he saw a guy yeah like in old
fashioned kind of clothes and so other
people have seen things here so at least
when they go there they do conduct a few
interviews with Canadia they do give you
an entertaining soundtrack it's edited
to be fast paced and exciting because a
real paranormal investigation just is
not exciting well it's a bunch of
sitting around but just sitting around a
bunch of taking no
it's about just setting up things yeah
bunch of nobody it's not conducive to an
exciting TV show no because a lot of
times a paranormal investigator will
just bug the house put a bunch of
cameras up and then leaves and nobody
being every three or four days yeah and
they just sit there well that's what
they should do because you're not
getting any there's no possibility the
day today's someone be there days and
days if not a sound if not a single
thing moving and this yeah you can't
make a show on that so we can say like
we can bust on Zach you know exact of
busting on you but I do know you
I do know that that's your job well yeah
that's that's what yeah but the funniest
thing about it and like I said I watched
they did two episodes on it and the
funniest thing about it I thought was
that Zach you know he makes a big deal
about going in and being all glenn
danzig about yeah yeah when it the ghost
and basically is like dropping as nuts
being like oh you you know you pushed a
pregnant woman down the stairs she's
like come [ __ ] with me or whatever yeah
and then later on in the show and I
can't imagine Zach is dancing that's
awesome that's why I thought of that I
know it's a weird Association so yeah so
he's like all big and bad and everything
like that saying yeah come and get me
come out and get me those other kind of
[ __ ] and then later on I don't remember
if it was the first show that they did
about on the second show later on
evidently one of the ghosts scratched
him there was like three you know the
famous three scratches it is that there
were actually scratches there you
couldn't see it on the night-vision
camera but on the regular camera you
could see it and he was like flipping
the [ __ ] out he was like it burns you ah
that's straight out of the Exorcist
so I was like so you come in here like a
big swinging dick talking about like
yeah come hurt me and then just like
push three little scratches down your
back and you're freaking the [ __ ] out
come on unlike you asked for that [ __ ]
right Cheers
- and didn't he kind of like a little
bit I think I'm this the second time
they were there they had a priest there
and he had talked to the priest on the
first episode and he was saying you know
the priest was saying you know I don't
think it's such a good idea for you to
be like going in there like oh damn oh
oh my dad's making like challenging that
goes to like hurt you and [ __ ] like that
that's really Steve glandt hey Glen
you got knocked the [ __ ] out dude I
thought although you did good Danzig's
defense anybody can knock anybody out
I've only seen like a handful of
episodes of Ghost Adventures cuz like I
said I just I have a hard time sitting
through a bit yeah but um another thing
is that zak always kind of has to be the
center of attention like if any time
there's like ghosts or they had their
little devices that are supposedly
ghosts talking to them it's job the
ghost always has to threaten him
specifically it always has to have it
always has to say something like I want
to kill Zach or I hate Zach or something
like that think I think is very
appealing the things that I think Zach
got that from what was his name Ryan
Buell from paranormal you paranoid that
show that like a reality show and then
Ryan Buell I think his name is Ryan
Buell but bill was definitely his last
name I remember but he'll was saying
that oh he saw something when he was a
little kid and this is the same ghost as
following him all these years you know
this demon kind of like something out of
the Exorcist you know yeah and picking
the priest you know out of the lineup
yeah I want that one and I kind of do
then bill ends up raising all this money
for this big thing that he was gonna do
and he runs off with all the cash -
stole everybody's money lost his program
anyway I think he's trying to do a
little bit of a Ryan Buell move yeah
where you're kind of like a reality TV
stars more about you as a character then
yeah it is about than it is about the
investor is not really a paranormal
program if they're all yeah and when you
look at the [ __ ] now it's not like when
we were young when you had like in
search of or
you know programs like that where they
would actually kind of look at the topic
nowadays television and cable TV
paranormal it's like it's like a Walmart
quality you know I mean it's not even
that even Walmart quality programs these
are all these are like pick and save
yeah I'm telling ya there's some one
there's only one of them that has any
merit to me and ghost brothers cuz ghost
brothers this nice funny ghost brothers
is funny yeah those dudes are funny
they're funny like they're already
taking it seriously but not they're not
really so you can see much the only one
I can sit there yeah because I like them
they're charming and like a good rapport
with each other now they used to have
taps and I think taps tried to take the
subject seriously for a few seasons but
then when they didn't get any results
yeah so that's starting to become a
reality television program about you
know about the guys that heard about led
to that and there was only a couple of
things that taps ever got on video that
was I thought was pretty weird one of
them was was video that they took
looking up a staircase of a lighthouse
you could see something kind of go up
and look like it jumped across that was
the only thing that bad name a
lighthouse now I should say like on this
on the Bobby Mackey episode of Ghost
Adventures
I mean this was the first show that they
did the first time they went there that
was their debut program and then they
went back like a year or two later and
they said that it was the worst place
they'd ever been like the the creepiest
or the most haunted place had ever been
and they claimed that things followed
them home one of the other guys I can't
remember with is it Nick or Aaron or
whatever the other guy's name is he said
that the ghosts that followed him home
from Bobby Mackey's like who contributed
to the breakup of his marriage and all
this other kind of stuff but didn't
didn't have anything do that other woman
he's like yeah I don't you know I'm sure
yeah yeah yeah but yeah and so it does
seem kind of like Zach was kind of on
the second show was kind of he didn't
come out and say that he was possessed
he was kind of hinting was like I don't
really feel that good and like acting
kind of weird and all this other kind of
stuff now the only interesting thing and
I still think it's probably fake but the
only interesting thing they got cuz like
I said they're walkin around Bobby
Mackey's and they're like did you hear
that - I'm like dude I don't I just
didn't hear anything it's like they just
didn't capture much and you know they
used the little machine that shows it
like that just runs throughout it and
now one thing they did get that I
thought was interesting was they were
filming I don't even know where it was
it looked like a cellar kind of place
and it was like a fridge and in the
background you could see what clearly
looked like a person like like a black
so it didn't look like a ghost or
nothing but it looked like so they were
like well now supposedly there was
nobody over there yeah yeah but it's
like I don't know that could have been a
stagehand they go over there and so we
doesn't get like a creeps yeah so we can
get like it is though is there run
around there and they're going did you
hear that oh yeah did you hear it there
it is there it is again and while all
that's going on they got background
music blaring so yeah I didn't determine
cuz they're sitting there going well did
you hear that I'm like did I hear what
like turn the skin like music down yeah
it they not only have music blaring in
the background they also have sound
effects like oh yeah yeah they're
talking about breathing that's talking
and stuff and I'm like how the [ __ ] can
I hear anything deaf as [ __ ] as it is
but it's like you know what I mean so
it's like yeah I'm not gonna hear
anything and then they play back the
EVPs they got and they're like oh listen
it said whatever it said I'm like uh no
I
yeah you could general I just couldn't
and I couldn't hear like what they were
saying that it says crap total crap but
yes so like I said I hope you guys
appreciate that I sent there two hours
of that yes you're like watching it was
really a joke you know I was doing other
stuff too it's nice
entertaining to me I don't know it's not
and I don't like well I don't like the
fast editing I don't like the fact that
they're just constantly running around
shouting I don't like I think that
there's like tons of noise going on all
the time when really it should be quiet
if they want to hear there's like only
five minutes of material there really
that it's kind of the interviews with
the people who yeah that was the only
part that was interested the rest of it
just expanded out into into
entertainment for somebody I don't know
who's entertained by that maybe it's a
very young demographic maybe 11 12 13 14
but do they spend money somebody's gonna
be watching it I mean like I said I just
I don't know I can't sit there yeah it's
just it's just they're all very very
same II yeah sound and fury signifying
nothing is that exactly what that show
is all right so we're pretty much at the
head of the show I think we can pretty
much everything we want to cover so if
any of you guys have been to Bobby
Mackey's and wanna tell me all oh wait
before we had a show though one thing we
have to mention is that when you go to
Bobby Mackey's you have Bobby mixers
Matt I don't believe in it they haven't
seen anything here yeah then you could
look outside this outside this huge size
we you know there's ghosts in here we
don't take any responsibility yeah I
said that no you okay yeah which I think
that's kind of odd you know and he's
been like giving his wife had been on a
[ __ ] ton I mean it wasn't just Ghost
Adventures
they've been on they were on there was a
show on I think it was on the Travel
Channel called the most terrifying place
in America they were on that show called
is it real so they're not shy about
turning up on TV you know much like I
said I'm not busting their bones about
that because I was do they've kept that
place open since 1978 so good on them
yeah anyway you can get
amen and it looked like it's being well
cared for it was remodeled since a sense
of haunting that's our so if that brings
people in ya know am I going
we all got am I going I want I want to
see I actually do - yeah just because
it's so famous I mean it's just kind of
like wait when we did the show about
Winchester house in says I'm always
going to go to that say oh yeah but I'm
always I'd I really don't think that I
would see anything I want the feeling
thing in the vibes yeah but you know I
still want to go just to me just because
I think just a house today more
interesting not well yeah just because
even if you don't like believe in ghosts
that's cool alright that'll do it for
episode 84 remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media share with all your friends
do all that other kind of stuff and if
you'd like to support the show you can
go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or if you
don't like patreon you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to make a one-time donation also
remember to check out our latest movie
review which was David Cronenberg's the
beroun if you haven't seen it and also
check out our Zazzle store in sazzle
dot-com / 13 o'clock and there's
t-shirts and a tote bag there if you
would like to purchase that and that
will do it for today's episode on Bobby
Mackey's music world see you next time
bye
[Music]
lived an old man and it's lovely little
daughter
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]